hi I'm going hi I'm Greg I'm John hi I'm
Joan Roca John wrote the Rochus said at
the Roca says on Twitter and Instagram
and he usually takes over for the rest
of his self remember what else every
Friday on collider movie talk i also
hosts a podcast with my friend Steve
Morris called the center files
Sena - files and on iTunes and set of
files on stitcher where me and him break
down one classic movie that was released
before the year 2007 because of 10 years
is kind of our window but we just bring
it down over an hour and a half talking
about his production history time with
casting and all that kind of jazz nice
Oh Andy outlaw main salon antonella's
gun is coming that is going to drop on
the schmoes no YouTube channel schmoes
no podcast channel very very soon and
I've invited these twofold
whoo these two rejects to come on the
show with me to argue about anything
they want to raise out we're targeting
Minnesota I'm very excited really weed
is not for children that's what I want
to Artie who is in the camp for this I
want to mean a couple of other people to
go very passionate about this and youth
up with a movie trivia slowdown champion
yeah that's right hey hey we've all seen
the mist in here haven't we a real good
movie this summer I watched the mist for
the first time today Humphrey to let me
borrow his blu-ray okay I hated anything
like everyone else's and not like that
ending but I love the movie overall
under the last couple minutes I love the
movie is there an alternate ending or is
Edna didn't ever shoot one oh you know I
don't know okay question I think that
might be actually all right I mean I
know the boys differently yes that book
does end differently and you've heard
the book there's no mist actually it is
very good it's just a day this super
sturdy groceries okay alright this is a
respite TV apparently the show got a lot
of requests for this let's watch this
minute and a half of what will be a lot
of hours of TV
well we see the miss
do not fear though couple nuns and
chameleon remember money lock the doors
I got I was which did we can't stay here
we gotta go now I believe this is
Judgment Day
Oh God here Arrowhead arrow do you I
felt something what did you feel that it
knew me that's what it does
screws with your mind
[Music]
and then mother nature's had enough
what whoa
that and it's different than the movie
Wow like becoming like American Horror
Story changed a little bit of walking
dead to me yeah I could see like a
little cove yeah good measures throw
along when I heard show I thought like
oh it's all going to take place in the
grocery store that we're just going to
get to know the characters really well
this is totally dipper you got the
grocery store element you got the church
element you got the story with the cops
you got soldier and then takes the mist
and goes what if it was everywhere else
in town yeah yeah looks like a real
psychological mind bug like yeah guys
guys kiss each other then he punches him
and that I'm the same guys having sex
with a woman later man man it's just a
sexual confusion I just that's why I was
really really good at first it was like
this needs to be steamy I didn't know
what my husband called them we're not
using it just fullest potential yeah but
you know what is always used to the
fullest potential frances conroy yeah
that's actually the most exciting thing
to me about this trailer is like she's
always one of my favorite things that
every season of American Horror Story oh
yeah oh yeah actually I'm great a creepy
old lady yeah yeah one of the few
characters in this trailer that seems
pretty distinct yeah there's a lot of
actors that I don't recognize in terms
of like knowing their names but I know
I've seen them on other things yeah and
so they fishing the way they cast
because every face it's unique it's
different it's not what you'd standards
see is it like a CW lead it's a little
more edgier their faces are more gaunt
and sharper edges or the cop has it like
a more of a granite face but that's
perfect because it kind of adds this
feeling of being off sentence yes I
imagine is what the woman is saying
which she's in the church like that's
what it does it messes with your mind so
that looks intact ma'am
this looks great I'm absolutely going to
what put this on the TV on it's crazy to
you Spike TV's be coming yeah yeah I
just saw they have a documentary I am
Heath Ledger's oh yeah and then they
have this and like they're becoming
everything you have tried to make an
actual television
now remember when they couldn't figure
out what network they want to call
themselves they were like T and N and
the men's channel yeah I felt like a
pyro channel the way it's shot it does
remind us have a little bit of that Ryan
Murphy flare doing it yeah I our feet in
like circle cross was like wayward Pines
oh yeah like oh yeah pine died like
small town paranoia yeah you know which
is I mean built into the original one
but that's what I'm the most curious
about this is just like I hope the
writing's good because there's a lot of
imagery of this trailer and not a lot of
people talking about stuff you know and
show their think be Catholic stuff
combined with the more live like demonic
symbols and they were doing the fast
jump cut yeah looks like it's going to
be a history exploration of that whole
thing yeah what is the truth what is not
true it seems like most people hiding
out in the church anyway for hell yeah
no I thought that was a good touch
because I like that implement when I
watch the movie today of all the
Christianity elements and more than just
a crazy Christian woman like it starts
to actually influence everyone deep
through the room yeah those people
behaved and divided and so that's even
more fascinating like watching today's
put its Rec one story it will just be
directly inside of a church right timing
you know so it's going to be like 10
times more religious what is this drink
in the day like they really it seems to
be like one other way only to tease what
could be a bonus because the first one
plays out kind of like there is a
definite monster movie vibe and I'm
almost wondering if this will be like a
better chance to get that smoke monster
motif right yeah okay they only come out
sometimes but when they do it means
something oh it looked like a livestock
or animal was going to they do the cops
car shut up in here oh yeah yeah we you
know every horror thing you gotta hit a
deer beer not a horror movie for not
killing deer you know we're like there's
a lot of every GI demons the movie I
thought was was really well done and I
thought when I heard sure I you know
what I said earlier what I thought it
would be doing this is probably the best
way you could translate it to television
yeah those are my favorite kind of
remakes in general where you take a
similar concept where you give us a
whole new set of characters different
environment different plot situations
but similar set up and to the set up of
this is
a mist invades of town and here's how
it's affecting the people in the town so
for this show to be effective we just
got to be very invested in these
characters and care about them when
they're going through this turmoil
otherwise it'll be like what you said
earlier just be like yes Bush [ __ ]
cool yeah but I'm really give a [ __ ]
about what's happening or anyone in the
movie and in the show and I think that's
why the problem and of course you can
explore this with Stephen King the
reason why a lot of his films don't
transfer positively to the big screen is
because he didn't have a storyteller a
very dense story lines of oh yeah or the
humanity of the characters you know what
it looks like the movie the remake looks
like niccola remake but like the first
feature film of it looks like they're
going to get that right but like there's
so many other things that don't so to me
this is the best way to tell Stephen
King stories could Jimmy he's really
format alright so you have enough time
just like I always thought the stand is
a great thing to be done doing a TV
series needful things a fantastic book
that not luck that like Emily was not
good enough to match how good that book
was there's so much to explore within
his books and if you haven't read his
stuff if you're a young viewer listener
now do these awesome dudes then go and
read his stuff read his stuff when he
was Bachman as well there's there's so
much to explore with Stephen King you'll
understand how to dissect story and
appreciate story and how to build
characters up and I think this show
looks like it's going to explore that
really really helpful yeah I think now
is a really good time for a Stephen King
style annotation to even great like TV
where embrace weirdest we've also
embraced the limited series I'm just
like you can you can line these novellas
and stuff like that you don't have to
keep them on forever like I feel like
now is a really fertile time for these
kinds of writers to get their stories
transcended and the shining made-for-tv
movie and the Carey made-for-tv movies
were the best things I've ever seen
personally what and I think that's what
makes me into the expert look in the
cabinet opinion goes out different
season Weber was so good even when in
him that shining so he blew Jack Nichols
and I fight like ever there was Jack as
the Joker and then heat as the Joker
Steven Weber was the chief ledger Wow
that's what Rose became Steven King came
out said that to the closest to the
camera yeah like it's like when James
Cameron said Terminator Genisys is the
reason for all off topic everyday
describing the real reject these reasons
the Jerry on Twitter and Instagram is a
social media manager of blue mouse and
the real reject John wrote goes on
everything we mentioned at the Rochus
says on Instagram and Twitter cameras
about the cut good night